je pense que c'est surtout de plus en
plus c'est comme ça que je ressent sur
le terrain c'est comme ça que je
longtemps sur le terrain
je pense que c'est de plus en plus une
illusion parce qu'il ya eu je pense une
arrivée comme il l'a dit lui même un peu
par effraction à la suite de
l'instrumentalisation des des affaires
qui ont fait que la droite a perdu cette
élection qui était imperdable je pense
pas que ce soit nos idées qu'ils aient
perdu ce sont c'est le contexte qui qui
a fait perdre et du coup voilà
aujourd'hui on est en train de de faire
l'addition de 1 an de gouvernement avec
de très très grande disparité entre ce
qu'il dit est ce que l'on ressent sur le
terrain la liste est très longue y
compris pendant les interviews ts sur
sur les réformes quand même il les
enchaîne il les tient il est fait c'est
je suis allé les fausses idées je vais
prendre un exemple concret il il n'y a
pas de ya pas de problème avec la
ruralité on ouvre des classes en plus
oui sauf que l'on ferme 808 classe le
solde entre ce qu on ouvrait ce qu'on
ferme c'est moins 808 sait pas plus
quelque chose sur la question des
djihadistes par exemple on va être très
très ferme
sauf qu' aucune mesure ferme n'est prise
et on compte no more attentats après
attentats on pleure mais qu'est ce qui
se passe derrière il se passe pas grand
chose donc sur tf1 vous l'avez pas
trouvé convaincant notamment
il y là il a remercié à plusieurs
reprises les retraités est ce que c'est
je veux pas dire que je n'ai pas trouvé
convaincant c'est un homme c'est un
homme de communication c'est un homme de
médias je pense que il a fait sur la
forme
parler de câlinothérapie c'est un
exercice de communication plutôt réussie
ration séduction c'est un exercice
plutôt réussie sur le plan de la
communication
mais sur le fond des choses demandées
aux retraités ce qu'il pense il dit je
remercie les retraités
franchement à président qui remercie une
catégorie sociale pour sa contribution
j'avais encore jamais trop entendu cela
quoi donc on sent on sent quelque chose
en ce moment fessée c'est un ressenti
tout à fait objectif où je sais je suis
pas un opposant permanent jeu plutôt je
suis encore 2
montrer j'ai plutôt quelqu'un qui
souligne les bonnes choses et je demande
depuis très longtemps je suis chef
d'entreprise je demande depuis très
longtemps
le fameux cic qui était une ânerie soit
converti en baisse de charges pérennes
il le fait c'est très bien il ya un
certain nombre de choses pour les
entreprises et pour les gens très riches
qui sont bonnes je ne conteste pas mais
pour le reste des millions de gens qui
sont inquiets pour leur avenir
je regarde sur le terrain et je constate
qu'entre une belle émission sur tf1
est ce que les gens vivent sur le
terrain ça risque d'être un boomerang
parce qu'ils se disent mais qu'est ce
qu'ils nous disent président